I think the worst thing Donald Trump did
as president was to refuse to accept a
result of the 2020 election and I think
it's an important part of the democratic
process even if it is a little bit dodgy
it's not totally compromised and you
should accept uh the result of it the
fact that Donald Trump didn't
was a bad thing he behaved recklessly he
did encourage people to think very
conspiritable thoughts and he did
undermine the Democratic process I think
in this particular case while Trump no
doubt behaved badly
what the indictment needs to prove is
what it claims which is that Trump
willfully knowing that he was spreading
lies about the election
tried to claim that it was stolen I
don't think they're going to be able to
do that I don't understand Trump's brain
nobody does but the fact is I think
Trump believes the election was dodgy
and therefore the fact that he still
does means that you can't really accuse
him of of willfully engaging in a
conspiracy